[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen den Sport in der Sendung hat
wieder Katja streso in ungefähr 15
Minuten guten Abend dann verschaffen wir
uns jetzt erstmal einen
Überblick besorgniserregende pisoten
deutsche Schüler schneiden wieder
schlecht ab vor allem soziale Herkunft
entscheidet über
Bildungschancen Förderung von E-Autos
die Automobilbranche befürchtet den
Wegfall der staatlichen
Kaufprämie und Ehrung für Ehrenamtliche
vom Schwimmkurs für kitaakinder bis zur
ukrainehilfe acht Initiativen werden mit
dem Deutschen Engagementpreis
ausgezeichnet wir starten mit dem
neuesten Pisa debarkel in die Sendung
nie waren deuts Schüler in lesen und
Mathe schlechter als jetzt erstmals
wurde die Bildungsstudie im Jahr 2000
erhoben und bescheinigte Deutschland
damals im internationalen Vergleich
miserable Schulleistung verantwortliche
waren schockiert und sind es jetzt
wieder gleich die Reaktionen zuvor
Christian Volk zu den
Ergebnissen jahrelang ging es Berg auf
mit den deutschen Pisa Ergebnissen im
Lesen in Mathematik und
Naturwissenschaften doch vor etwa 10
Jahren ein Umschwung und aktuell der
Tiefpunkt die Leistungen in allen
Bereichen abgesagt Mathematik hier sieht
es besonders schlecht aus 30% der
15-Jährigen gelten laut Studie als
leistungsschwach sie könnten etwa nur
schwer berechnen ob sich ein
Sonderangebot beim Einkaufen lohnt oder
nicht Lesekompetenz 25% der Schüler sind
schwach im Lesen so die Studie demnach
können sie nicht die Hauptaussage eines
mittellangen Textes erfassen
Naturwissenschaften 23% gelten hier laut
Untersuchung als leistungsschwach ihnen
sei es kaum möglich
naturwissenschaftliche Phänomene wie
etwa den Vogelzug zu erklären insgesamt
zeigen die Ergebnisse ein noch immer
sozialungerechtes Schulsystem Leistungen
häen mehr als in anderen Ländern von
Bildungsgrad und Geldbeutel der Eltern
ab und es gebe große Unterschiede
zwischen Kindern mit und ohne
Migrationshintergrund etwa in Mathe oder
beim Lesen die Ergebnisse für
zugewanderte Kinder bezeichnen die
Forscher als
alarmierend alarmierende Befunde also
und weil Bildungserfolg in Deutschland
eben stärker als in anderen Ländern von
sozialer Herkunft abhängt darf man davon
ausgehen dass die pisaergebnisse wieder
eine hitzige Bildungsdebatte entfachen
werden mehr von Stefanie
Hein sie geben sich Mühe jeden Tag doch
trotzdem beim aktuellen pisatest sieht
es für Deutschlands Schulen insgesamt
düster aus wie noch nie was wir in
Deutschland feststellen ist dass die
soziale Herkunft noch immer die
Leistungen in der Bildung
voraussagt auch dass akademische
Spitzenleistungen weitgehend das
Privileg sind der sozial
bessergestellten das ist in Deutschland
eher mehr der Fall als in anderen
Ländern ein ungerechtes System beklagen
die Betroffenen selber Lücken durch
Corona sieht der Generalsekretär der
bundesschüler als Problem dazu
Chancenungleichheit und vor allem den
Lehrermangel es kann nicht sein dass
Lehrkräfte einerseits Lehrkräfte sind
gleichzeitig Bibliothekare
pausenaufsichten und
schulsozialulszialarbeiter ichbt auch in
eigen Haut bei mir fällt oft Unterricht
aus da muss ich mir selber Sachen
beibringen mit Schulbücher mit Youtube
Videos aber für uns ist ganz klar das
ist kein Ersatz für Lehrkräfte
Schulleitungen beklagen viele Kinder
sind schon nach der Grundschule
frustriert weil sie immer wieder
Misserfolgserlebnisse haben weil sie
immer wieder erleben dass das was an
Anforderung an sie gestellt wird sie
nicht erfüllen können und das führt dazu
dass sie aufhören mutig zu sein zu
lernen Lust am Lernen zu haben die
Politik sieht dass die Bemühungen sehr
früh beginnen müssen wenn wir über die
Stärkung der Basiskompetenzen sprechen
müssen wir vor einitt der Schule
anfangen nämlich im frühkindlichen
Bereich dass wir in den kitest den Orten
der frühen Bildung anfangen dort
spielerisch vorzubereiten um den
Übergang auch bestmöglich zu gestten
so soll es gelingen mehr Gerechtigkeit
und insgesamt bessere Leistungen zu
erreichen jetzt zum Krieg in Nahost die
Kämpfe haben sich in den Süden des
gasastreifens verlagert immer mehr
schweres Gerät wird dorthin verlagert
allerdings bereitet das weit verzweigte
Tunnelsystem der Hamas erhebliche
Probleme weswegen angeblich sogar über
eine Flutung nachgedacht wird Israels
Armee spricht heute vom intensivsten Tag
seit Beginn der Bodenoffensive Anne brü
mit aller Macht rückt die israelische
Armee in Gaza weiter vor und spricht von
den intensivsten kämpfen seit Beginn der
Bodenoffensive in hananunes im Süden
gibt es Tote wie viele weiß
keiner wir waren in einer Schule einem
sicheren Ort sie haben die erste Rakete
auf uns gefeuert Menschen wurden
zerfetzt Ohren Münder Hände und die
arabischen Regierungen schauen
zu israelische Militär veröffentlicht
diese Bilder gezielte Angriffe auf
Stellungen der Hamas auf ihre
Tunnelanlagen es gibt Vorbereitungen die
Tunnel mit Wasser zu fluten die
Verstecke der Hamas die Menschen in Gaza
wurden aufgefordert bestimmte Zonen zu
verlassen zu Ihrer
Sicherheit wir evakuieren die
Bevölkerung aus der
Kampfzone wir treffen Hamas von oben und
unten ägen a der Luft der See und von
Land es ist das Dilemma Israels denn es
sind die Bilder der vielen Toten und
Verletzten die sich einbrennen
katastrophale Zustände in den
Krankenhäusern die auch das
Internationale Rote Kreuz
anprangert wir müssen Lösungen dafür
finden wir können uns nicht abwenden von
etwas das offensichtlich ein moralisches
Versagen vor den Augen der
Weltgemeinschaft ist
auch die Hamas greift weiter Israel an
Tel Aviv und Aschkelon wurden getroffen
seit Kriegsbeginn hat die Hamas mehr als
10 000 Raketen
abgefeuert knapp vier Wochen bis zum
neuen Jahr aber wie genau der
Bundeshaushalt für 2024 aussehen soll
noch ziemlich unklar zu unterschiedlich
die Ansichten in der Ampel wie das
Milliardenloch im Budget zu stopfen ist
seit einer guten Stunde sitzen Kanzler
Scholz Wirtschaftsminister habbeck und
Finanzminister Lindner wieder im
Kanzleramt zusammen und die Zeit wird
knapp um den Haushalt 2024 noch in
diesem Jahr durchs Parlament zu bringen
sollte bald eine Grundsatzentscheidung
her angepeilt ist ja morgen die
Kabinettssitzung und wir wollen
Nachfragen bei shakunal La benerji
klappt denn ein Kompromiss zur
Kabinettssitzung was hörst du in Berlin
wenn man unter demem Kompromiss ein
fertigen Haushaltsvorschlag
erwartet oder sich vorstellt dann wird's
wahrscheinlich schwierig da hören wir
heute dass die Kabinettssitzung morgen
wahrscheinlich nicht mit einem Beschluss
Arbeiten wird also die Sitzung heute
Nacht wird wahrscheinlich nicht reichen
um alle Fragen dann vom Tisch zu holen
wenn das nicht klappt muss aber relativ
relativ schnell eine Einigung her
wenigstens mal auf die Eckpunkte denn
Ziel ist ganz offensichtlich immer noch
den Haushalt noch in diesem Jahr
durchzubekommen möglichst durch
Bundestag und Bundesrat aber da gibt es
Fristen und wenn man die nicht reißen
will dann muss man also morgen oder
spätestens übermorgen fertig werden so
hören wir und dafür ist eben noch eine
ganze Menge Arbeit nötig momentan sitzen
eben Olaf Scholz Robert habbeck und
Christian Lindner zusammen Scholz und
habbeck haben extra ihre Reisepläne
geändert dafür also der Wille ist da
aber man muss sich wirklich noch
zusammenraufen und jeder Tag der vergeht
ohne eine Einigung bedeutet dann noch
eben Abstriche von dem gemeinsamen Ziel
noch bis Jahresende fertig zu werden
schakunel vielen Dank nach Berlin ja das
Haushaltsloch das verunsichert auch die
Automobilbranche der viele Hersteller
haben auf Fördersummen vom Bund gesetzt
als Kaufanreiz um den Absatz von E-Autos
anzukurbeln bislang sind in Deutschland
ja nur rund 1,3 Millionen
vollelektrische PKW registriert das Ziel
der Ampel das liegt deutlich höher 15
Millionen E-Autos bis 2030 nämlich auf
die Straße bringen ohne Geld vom stat
klappt das nicht klagt die Branche
Alexander Pool und Peter
aeer für den Bundeskanzler ist der
Besuch des BMW Stammwerke S in München
ein klares Bekenntnis zur
Automobilindustrie und er hat auch etwas
mitgebracht eine deutliche Portion
Optimismus etwas was Teilen der
Industrie zurzeit fehlt wer hier
Produktion sieht und die ganzen
Veränderung begleiten kann der geht hier
weg mit dem sicheren Gefühl das wird uns
gelingen das wird unser Land schaffen
was der Kanzler nicht mitgebracht hat
sind klare Zusagen für den weiteren
Umbau zur Immobilität die Haushaltskrise
TR diese Entwicklung nun auszubremsen
besonders wenn Subventionen wie die
Umweltprämie für E-Autos zur Diskussion
stehen nach wie vor sind die
Elektroautos sehr sehr teuer und diese
Umweltprämie haben diesen diesen großen
Preisunterschied zwischen Elektroautos
und Verbrennern zum Teil aufgehoben
Experten seh genau diese umweltprämier
für E-Autos sogar kritisch diese würde
den falschen Anreiz geben gerade bei der
Elektromobilität muss man aber aufpassen
es geht nicht nur um Investitionen
insbesondere nicht nur um Zuschüsse
sondern wir müssen sehen dass D vor
allem der CO2 Preis da zum Zuge kommt
das heißt es muss sich lohnen
Elektroautos zu kaufen weil Benzin mit
seiner Klimabelastung teurer wird
wichtig für den erfolgreichen Umstieg
auf die eemobilität so der Verband der
Autoindustrie sei besonders der Ausbau
der Ladeinfrastruktur wie der Umstieg
zur Mobilität künftig durch die Politik
gefördert wird das muss der Kanzler mit
seinen Koalitionspartnern nun
entscheiden der weltweite CO2 Ausstoß
durch fossile Energieträger wird dieses
Jahr ein Rekordhoch erreichen das zeigt
eine neue Studie wobei die
Kohlendioxidemissionen regional sehr
unterschiedlich sind in der Europäischen
Union werden dieses Jahr 7,4% weniger
des klimaschädlichen Gases ausgestoßen
als im Vorjahr in den USA wird ein Minus
von 3% erwartet dagegen steigen die
Werte in Indien und China in Indien wird
es ein emissionsplus von
8,2% sein in China werden 4% mehr CO2
aus
ausgestoßen im Tarifstreit im
öffentlichen Dienst der Länder steht
übermorgen die nächste Verhandlungsrunde
an die Gewerkschaften machten heute noch
einmal Druck in Düsseldorf
demonstrierten 15 000 Beschäftigte
unterschiedlicher Berufe für höhere
Löhne und Gehälter werdi fordert 10inh%
mehr Geld mindestens aber 500 €
monatlich die Länder lehnen das als
nicht bezahlbar
ab fast 4er Jahre liegt der Anschlag von
hannau jetzt schon zurück heute wurde im
hässischen Landtag der Abschlussbericht
des Untersuchungsausschusses diskutiert
am 19 Februar 2020 hatte ein 43-Jähriger
aus rassistischen Gründen neun Menschen
aus Zuwanderer Familien erschossen die
Aufarbeitung der Tat die ist für die
Politik jetzt beendet für die
Angehörigen längst nicht denn sie
vermissen Konsequenzen Susanne
Santina suchungsausschuss hat bestätigt
was Julia und nikolesku Paun ihre
Unterstützer und Medien schon vorher
rausgefunden hatten ihr Sohn Willi wurde
getötet nachdem er den Täter nach den
ersten Morden beobachtet und mit seinem
Auto verfolgt hatte den Notruf den er
mehrfach wählte konnte er nicht
erreichen weil die Polizei Hanner
unterbesetzt und das Notrufsystem
veraltet war viele fehle von Polizei
seit 2016 wir brauchen Konsequenzen der
Abschlussbericht des uausschusses wurde
heute ab schließend diskutiert mit dabei
viele Angehörige nur die in Hessen
Regierenden Grünen und die CDU stimmten
dem kompletten Bericht zu die SPD
beschloss z.B ein Sondervotum zum
technisch veralteten Notruf es ist nicht
nachweisbar dass der Innenminister und
auch der
Polizeipräsident explizit davon gewusst
haben es ist aber nicht plausibel dass
das nicht bekannt war auch bezüglich des
verschlossenen Notausgangs in der
arenabar haben die Angehörigen
weitgehend Recht bekommen der Sohn von
Familie kurtwit Hamsa wurde in der
renabar erschossen genauso wie
seitnesser Haschemi der Notausgang war
wieder rechtlich zu aber wer übernimmt
Verantwortung ich wünsche mir
Konsequenzen es kann doch nicht sein
dass Polizeibeamte anordnen dass
Notausgänge verschlossen werden der
Verdacht dass der Notausgang
verschlossen wurde weil es einen Deal
der Polizei mit dem Barbesitzer gab um
Razen zu erleichtern konnte der
uausschuss nicht bestätigen das ist
irgendwelche Absprachen mit wem auch
immer im Hinblick auf den Ausgang
gegeben hat und das war nicht erweislich
am Ende des uausschusses steht eine
Entschuldigung bei den Angehörigen der
Opfer weil es den Behörden nicht
gelungen sei sie vor einem rassistischen
Anschlag zu
schützen
ehrenamtliche Einsatz findet jeden Tag
fernab von Kameras und Scheinwerferlicht
statt heute aber wurde der rote Teppich
ausgerollt für acht Initiativen die mit
dem Deutschen Engagementpreis
ausgezeichnet wurden mit dabei ein
Angebot des Deutschen Roten Kreuzes in
Meklenburg Vorpommern dort bringen Kita
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter Kindern
das Schwimmen bei Susanne Seidel weiß
mehr das sind einige der Gewinner und
Gewinnerinnen des deutschen Engagement
Preises das Bündnis für Gemeinnützigkeit
ehrt damit jährlich engagierte Menschen
und
Initiativen unsere Gesellschaft würde
nicht funktionieren wenn es das Ehrenamt
nicht gäbe 28 Millionen Menschen sorgen
dafür dass deutch dann funktioniert und
das Mindeste was wir tun können ist wenn
es solche großartigen Menschen gibt sie
mit einem Engagementpreis auch zu Ehren
mit dabei das Projekt rette sich wer es
kann schwimmen lernen im Kindergarten
seit 2010 bringen DRK Mitglieder Kita
Kindern in Mecklenburg vorpommen das
Schwimmen bei und schaffen so
Chancengleichheit im Kindergarten sind
alle Kinder zusammen ob sie jetzt aus
Arbeit derfilien kommen oder
irgendwelche anderen sozialen Schichten
wir haben auch
migrationskinder mit dabei ca 140
Erzieherinnen und Erzieher hat das
Projekt inzwischen zu Schwimmlehrern
ausgebildet so können viele Kitakinder
schwimmen lernen noch vor der
Einschulung das ist glaube ich bekannt
dass es in vielen Schulen mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr stattfindet weil
Schwimmlehrer fehlen oder Schwimmhallen
fehlen und wir versuchen praktisch eine
eine Stufe oder eine Ebene vorher
anzusetzen das Seepferdchen Abzeichen
ein erster Schritt auf dem Weg zum
sicheren Schwimmer men hat geschafft ne
Schnee und Eis haben am Morgen in
verschiedenen Teilen des Landes zu
zahlreichen Unfällen und Einschränkungen
geführt im Erzgebirge kam ein Schüler
bei einem schulbusunfall ums Leben der
Bus war mit einem Fahrzeug des
Winterdienstes zusammengestoßen und dann
frontal gegen einen Baum geprallt 13
weitere Menschen wurden verletzt am
Flughafen München fielen am Vormittag
wegen Eisregens hunderte Verbindungen
aus seit dem Mittag läuft der Flug
Verkehr wieder
an jetzt zum Sport und die deutschen
Handballerinnen Katja haben ihre weiße
Weste gewahrt ja bei der WM in
Skandinavien haben sie auch das dritte
und letzte Vorrundenspiel eindrucksvoll
gewonnen gestern gegen Polen und stehen
nun mit perfekter Punkteausbeute in der
Hauptrunde die GAL Vorstellung im
dänischen Herning wird den meisten wohl
unvergessen bleiben auch am Tag danach
freute sich das dhbteam noch immer über
die Glanzparaden von Katarina Filter und
die unglaublich effektive Abwehrarbeit
beim 33 z17
Erfolg da haben wir einfach Beton
angerührt haben es den richtig schwer
gemacht ich fand auch dass man gemerkt
hat richtig dass die Polin nach Lösung
gesucht haben und keine richtigen
gefunden haben als Gruppensieger nehmen
die deutschen jetzt 4:0 Punkte mit in
die Hauptrunde und jede Menge
Selbstvertrauen jetzt kommen vermutlich
Rumänien Serbien Dänemark auf uns zu
aber wir freuen uns auf die Aufgaben am
Donnerstag geht's weiter mit dem ersten
Spiel in der
Hauptrunde
und in 14 Minuten ist anfiff in der
Fußball nations League der Frauen
Deutschland trifft in Swansea auf Wales
es ist das letzte Gruppenspiel es geht
um den Gruppensieg denn nur dann ist das
Team von horstrubesch im Finalturnier
und spielt um das Ticket für Olympia und
um den Einzug ins Viertelfinale des DFB
Pokals geht es heute und morgen Abend
dann für die Männer der BFB muss nach
der BVB muss nach Stuttgart dorthin wo
sie zuletzt keine allzu guten Erfahrung
gemacht hat
Dortmund Sportdirektor Kehl und die BVB
Spieler geradezu geschockt nach dem
letzten Bundesliga Auftritt in Stuttgart
vor dreieinhalb Wochen die ein Z2
Niederlage mehr als schmeichelhaft in
Anbetracht der vielen Torchancen die
Stuttgart nicht genutzt hatte der VfB
turmhoch überlegen das sitzt noch immer
tief im Bewusstsein ihres Trainers ja
ausblenden kann man das ganze nicht
wollen wir auch nicht aber besser machen
vor allem müssen sie die beiden
treffsichersten Stuttgarter in den Griff
bekommen Toptorjäger girassi und seinen
immer besser in Fahrt kommenden
Sturmpartner Denis
undarf und das Spiel kannst du unter
anderem morgen Abend im ZDF sehen gut
vielen Dank Katja ja glette bleibt ein
Thema mehr Details gleich mit Katja
horneffer im Wetter das heute journal ab
21:45 Uhr mit Marietta Slomka danke vom
gesamten 19 Uhr Team fürs zuschauen und
bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute viele nicht nur Schnee
und Regen sondern auch ganz gefährlicher
Glatteisregen und das recht verbreitet
in Deutschland hier im Nordosten
inzwischen sind die Schneewolken ganz im
Nordosten angekommen es regnet kräftig
im Südwesten in den Mittelgebirgen ist
nach wie vor auch Schnee dabei sie
sollten sich auch heute Nacht noch mal
auf Glätte einstellen einem Streifen von
Bremen bis nach Berlin nördlich davon
fät Schnee sonst kommt Regen aus den
Wolken raus und nur in den
Mittelgebirgen Schnee im Schwarzwald
können bis morgen Abend durchaus noch
mal 15 cm Neuschnee fallen und im
kräftigen Südwestwind wird der dann auch
verweht die Temperaturen in der Nacht
sinken auf 4° am oberrehein und bis -3°
ganz im Osten und morgen liegen dann die
Höchsttemperaturen an der Ostsee um 0°
am Rhein werden max mal 6° erreicht
morgen früh kann es noch gefährlich
glatt sein hier im Nordosten dann aber
lassen die Schnee und Regenfälle doch
mehr und mehr nach und es kommt von
Westen doch allmählich die Sonne zum
Vorschein und das ist ein kleines
Zwischenhoch das uns dann am Donnerstag
beehrt nach Nebel zeigt sich dann
häufiger die Sonne aber am Freitag kommt
von Westen schon gleich wieder der
nächste Glatteisregen auf und zum
zweiten Adventswochenende setzt
Tauwetter ein guten
Abend